so my name is Andy Wingo I work for a
company out of Spain called Eagle iya we
do a lot of consulting around WebKit and
as such I've gotten into javascriptcore
a bit javascriptcore is the the
javascript engine of the WebKit project
itself in fact a bit on VA before on
JavaScript core but in reality I'm a
traveler in foreign lands here's my
heart is from scheme language so it's
interesting coming into these
implications from the outside and seeing
you know what's really going on and the
tag for this talk had a bit of hubris
associate with it I think claiming that
JavaScript cores as fast as v8 on its
own benchmark and as we'll see that that
claim has a shape to it and some of that
shape is true and some that shape is not
quite true yet but let's take a look at
the DFG at the optimizing compiler of
the JavaScript core engine and see you
know what is it that it actually does so
it as I mention the the DFG is
JavaScript course optimizing compiler
you know the standard architecture of
these JavaScript engines is you have
something for dealing with cold code and
something for dealing with hot code and
for javascriptcore we have the low-level
interpreter for very cold code there's
an intermediate phase with what we call
the baseline JIT which is a jit that
doesn't do any global analysis or
optimization and then we have the DFG
jutt which is able to take a bit more
time it has a bit more information and
it take a bit more of a global view on
your program so this much is fairly well
known but I don't think it's very you
know well understood you know what what
it is that this engine does with your
code and how it works and you know what
does performance characteristics are so
I would like to take a more empirical
approach to it I would like to you know
measure the dfgg it and see how it does
on various representative test cases and
see ya when it does this when when is it
kick in what are its dynamic
characteristics not simply you know
performance as a number which is great
for the marketing folks but performance
as a shape and distribution which is
much more interesting from a perspective
understanding the software I'd also take
like to take a look at the assembly code
that is produced by this so I promise it
won't be all assembly back I think it's
kind of interesting to see how your
javascript is translated into what
machine code when you run on a browser
with javascript poor so as my tool in
this regard i'm going to use the the v8
benchmarks v8 version 7 benchmarks and
these benchmarks are really geared
towards optimizing compilers right they
don't test anything else in your system
they test your optimizing the output of
your optimizing compiler and and also
your garbage collector as well and the
reason you can know about these is they
take quite a long time to run and they
take a long time I run because they take
a full second to warm up the code for
each benchmark and then they measure
over another second how they take a
number of iterations until you get up to
a second of iterations of these
benchmarks and they they divide the time
by the iterations and you get a time per
iteration and that that time ends up
going on the denominator of the results
so that you know higher values on the v8
benchmark as we all know actually
correspond to higher performance and so
it's very good for measuring you know
the best that your compiler can do but
it's it's not so good for you know
investigating characteristics of the
invitation I will take a look first
though it you know what are these
numbers I have a graph here i'm not sure
if these numbers are terribly visible to
y'all the green bars correspond to this
baseline JIT which doesn't do any global
analysis in the yellow bars correspond
to the DFG jet which is the optimizing
compiler and you can see on you know we
get three and four times improvements
except on the regular expression one
which I'll talk a little bit later about
now I want to also use this graph to
introduce a idea I'm trying to work on
this presentation it's probably not you
know finish and can be much better but
it's that you know performance is not
simply a number it is a distribution
that you can sample you need to take a
number of samples and see you know what
is the range of performance that I
expect so at the top of all these
bars I've got little histograms
superimposed I don't know what I'm doing
this quite right anyway but you can see
like for example on this DFG jet
histogram we see that they're all very
tightly clustered whereas on this other
dfgg histogram we have a bimodal
distribution they're pretty tight you
know but they're your performance tend
to cluster those two values and that's
something you really can't capture with
the median and I'm going to use this
sort of thing as we go forward to really
pull apart some of these benchmarks and
really I'm not going to use to the
straight v8 benchmarks to as my tool I'm
going to hack them a bit too to see what
are the dynamic characteristics of the
DFG I'm going to make the warm-up time
variable starting from Nam warm-up at
all all the way up to a second with more
samples closer to zero so after zero
milliseconds after five milliseconds
after 10 milliseconds meaning after 10
milliseconds you know what's the
performance I can expect on my webpage
with javascriptcore after 25
milliseconds what's what's the kind of
performance I can expect and then the
thing I measure after the warm-up is
going to be 5 milliseconds of a runtime
and it it's a good measure of the code
that the DFG can produce but it's a it's
a very tricky measurement as well
because it's sensitive let's say in
those five milliseconds milliseconds
where I'm measuring you know what if GC
hits well you know I I'm going to get
much worse results for that particular
run for example or what if the optimizer
decides to optimize a lot of code in
that 5 millisecond window well you know
also I can I can experience some
slowdowns oh and as well we have some
issues with timer precision in
JavaScript for memory for measuring
these things I'm using that more precise
timer that's available in the JC runtime
called precise time which gives me a bit
more precision in this regard but all of
these things you know these unexpected
pauses these you know sources of
variation in performance can also affect
your real code so i think it's is not
unfair to actually be measuring these
things so in this experiment more than
other ones we really need to take a look
at this shape
performance again and see you know
what's going on went out of the way
let's take a look at the first v8
benchmark which is a Richards benchmark
it's a scheduler and it uses some bit
operations for maintaining the states of
tasks in the scheduler and it uses a
bunch of objects with properties and
prototype resolution and such what we
can see here is that you know here at
zero milliseconds we're starting off
with pretty poor performance which is
natural you don't want to spend your
time optimizing code that you don't know
is going to run but after you know 5
milliseconds 10 milliseconds certainly
after 75 milliseconds we're up to our
peak performance these vertical lines
indicate runs of the optimizing compiler
so you can see if they're all clustered
before 75 but you probably can't even
read that let's go to 0 5 10 15 25 4075
one 2203 2,500 seven hundred a thousand
milliseconds right so from zero to one
second this is your the dynamic profile
of the DFG performance and what we see
graphed here is the distribution of
performance results that I've taken so
for I for example warmed up v 8 40
milliseconds and then measured the next
five milliseconds 50 times alright and
those 50 values are applied here same
for 5 milliseconds st. for 10 I don't
know I tried to make it understandable
but it's a it's a novel graph kind and
that never goes over quite so well what
we see though is performance is fairly
tightly clustered the paint there's more
paint that means that there's a higher
variance in in the performance and here
we see things are fairly tight it goes
up drops down a bit for some reason I
don't quite understand but then no
optimizing compiler run happens after 75
milliseconds so 75 milliseconds in this
benchmark and the DFG is done all that
it sees fit to do and so we get a three
point seven times performance increase
1.0 would be no no increase at all on
this particular benchmark relative to
the baseline JIT measured over a full
second and now we get in a hardcore
stuff
one of the things that turned out we'll
just take an example of one of the
functions that that we went to optimize
here I don't know how many of you have
looked at the source code for the v8
benchmarks few y'all the engine hackers
I see right so the rest of y'all here's
the JavaScript up here we add something
to a task saying you know is suspended
we do a bit and compare and we have
another clause that their logical order
together and we return it and the
assembly that's below is what you can
see on the screen right now corresponds
to this this dot state bitwise and with
state held first we get this which is a
local variable and that's just a memory
reference we checked that this has the
prototype that we saw when it was
initially compiled but it was optimized
and if it does not have this prototype
we're going to jump to this bailout
which one we d optimize which might be a
word you've heard from other discussions
of optimizing compilers like crankshaft
for example then we once we verified
that the this object has the shape that
we're expecting we directly reference a
field in the object using you know what
with the v8 folks called hidden classes
we get the global variable corresponding
to state held so unfortunately we didn't
in line this to a constant but okay and
then we go ahead and do the bitwise and
the first four instructions correspond
to type checks that the this state and
the state held are both integers are 14
this is a 64-bit assembly code and are
14 holds the number tag so we compare
the number tag on the on the value
javascriptcore uses the nan boxing
technique nan boxing folks heard of it
yeah awesome you guys great if you
haven't heard of it you know search nan
boxing on the web also search for an
unboxing and I don't think there's you
know any pugilistic encounters but not I
don't know finally after this we have
some comparisons we compared the the
value to 0 we invert it we actually
store it to memory that's the set local
and we do
branch and and this is sub-optimal to be
honest like many of these things could
be joined together but you know this
this these are the instructions that are
produced for that in a very first part
of this function there are some more and
finally we return and then after the end
of the main path all the bailouts all
the points where we you know jump too if
something wasn't expected I gotta check
myself because I could talk about this
forever that's just the first benchmark
so the second is Delta blue it's a
constraint solver and we get a fine
speed up on this one we get a bit more
more paint here as you can see there's
more yellow there's more variance
towards there and I'll talk a little bit
more about what that means but on this
one it's very it's very important to in
line but we see some bit if I look at
the logs and i'll i'll talk about how to
get the logs a little bit later I think
yeah we see some entries like delaying
optimization for this thing and it's
called in a loop because we have
insufficient profiling and so this
indicates that you know for this
optimizing compiler as with all
JavaScript optimizing compilers we need
what they call profiling which is the
the runtime type feedback the type
information and there's actually a an
option to tweak how much it weights or
doesn't wait for some profiling
information and in this case it hits the
maximum of five attempts to profile so
it starts first it up after twenty
milliseconds and then eventually after
trying again for more times that at 40
milliseconds in it goes ahead and
increase the optimized code it's like it
would like more information so it's
going to wait for it it waits doesn't
find it so it produces a code that's a
general flavor of things this is I look
through the logs for you know what kinds
of functions were actually compiled in
this early phase and if I go back to the
graph sorry for switching back and forth
we see that you know it's really between
15 and 25 and 40 milliseconds is where
we start to jump up to our level and
that's that's generally the time range
that you're optimizing compiler will
kick in and I saw this is one of the
functions it doesn't look very hot to me
I'm
I haven't actually run the damn profiler
and seen if this is hot but you know
just looking to code it didn't look like
it was going to be something that was
particularly hot and what I what that
indicates to me is that here we just
have a lot of work to do and indeed if
we go back apologize again going back we
see a lot more vertical lines in this
one compared to richards and they go a
lot later you know they go after 75 it
seems like oh there's some out all the
way up at a thousand and I'm sure if it
ran for more more would run so some code
especially code with small functions it
needs a bunch of inlining and such it's
going to take some more work to be
optimized Richard's the the previous
example it was a bit simpler for the DFG
to work with the next one is a crypto
crypto is kind of interesting it deals a
lot with integers and it deals a lot
with arrays as well again we see a lot
of lines the there you can see some
notable clustering as well clustering is
like when a line is bigger that's
because two lines are drawn really close
together the DFG optimizer will kick in
based on a profile count so for example
a loop executes a thousand times or
something and that can lead to
clustering because there are a lot of
loops and functions whose execution
counts are linked you know if you call
this function a thousand times then this
loop will run five thousand times and
this other function will run a thousand
times so they can all kick in about the
same time so you can you can get this
sort of clustering effect it usually
doesn't affect performance I don't think
maybe it can cause an affirmation
optimization slow down but no no it's an
interesting characteristic but I like
this one because crypto is a great
benchmark to optimize because there's
lots of you know classical compiler
optimizations that you know us compiler
nerds really really dig on and this is a
one of the functions that's in the
benchmark because we can see you know we
have a lot of integer operations trying
to keep in the range of integers that
are efficient in JavaScript and if I
take a look at one of the particular
lines which is fetching a value from an
array and then doing a bitwise and with
constant we can see that we get the
array which which is this array we fetch
that out from memory we get I which for
some reason is in memory as well I don't
think it's actually a good idea for it
to be in memory but okay and we get this
this is actually a relatively new thing
just landed about a month ago this
butterfly representation this is a way
in the future to store out of line data
like the elements in an array to
potentially store them as unbox values
it's not completely taken advantage of
yet and I think it's one of the things
that in JavaScript core in the DFG will
start to see in the next couple months
or so but this is a pointer to either a
small amount of inline data so if your
array only has two elements for example
they're probably going to be allocated
in the same block as your as your object
or a pointer to out of line data
containing the rest of the array the get
byval checks that the integers and
bounds up for the array and if not it
bails out fetches the value and checks
if the value is a hole and if not it
bails out and then finally we do a
bitwise and another thing that I wasn't
mentioning before is that between these
operations these operations are the part
of the internal representation of the
DFG compiler so they don't they
correspond loosely the things that you
need to do semantically in JavaScript
but they don't correspond exactly the
bytecode they don't correspond exactly
to the the specification either but what
we see is that for example we have we
get this array and we put it in our 10
and then down here we use our 10 and
then later on we can use a we can use
these values directly in those registers
register allocation is you know
obviously a huge optimization that all
of the optimizing compilers do and so
even if you don't have a lot of type
information in running the optimizing
compiler on a piece of code can still be
quite advantageous right so raytrace
here we have an interesting example is
the first floating-point example and
VA test suites it uses some
floating-point math and it uses objects
with floating point fields so like this
X being a floating point number we see
very tight performance here and then we
as we warm up a bit more we start to see
a bit more variance and whenever you see
variance in a very small benchmark like
this it means that something is slowing
down the benchmark sometimes but not
some other times so any guesses as to
what this could be in this particular
case yes yes exactly the reason we have
so much variance and you probably can
see this right now but it goes from here
all the way to hear there's a histogram
line drawn there is because sometimes we
hit garbage collection and sometimes we
don't in the right trace example we get
a lot of short-lived objects with
floating point fields so you can you can
get very good performance as long as you
don't have GE and if you do hit GC you
get less performance and I'll talk about
that a bit more when we get to the more
strong tests of the garbage collector
later as one example of code that the
DFG works with for this one we have this
normalized function and it takes a
vector and it returns a new vector and
at normal I normalized as it compiles
dysfunction when the DFG gets to this
top magnitude it's going to inline the
code for this magnitude which is pretty
awesome optimization I also done by
other other systems but you know it's
pretty key to do and I just want to
focus a bit on what happens when we
store the result for this x divided by M
we ended up dividing by things they're
placed in SSC registers so it's just one
instruction after we've loaded up the
values but then when we go to store it
we re add a number tag on a value in the
high beds to the value or I think it
rotates the value around actually and
and we store it as a sort of general
JavaScript object which only occupies
one word but in into this object which
means that we don't have fields that are
unboxed values in javascript core we
have this decks can be like an in 32 for
example or this that X can be a float
and we always know it's a float
otherwise we you know we would leave off
this tagging step early Boyer again we
see a lot of paint because we see a lot
of short-term allocations these are two
benchmarks that were translated from
scheme actually by an automatic
translator by same fellow that does the
dart to JavaScript translator in cinelli
and so what we see are a lot of calls to
small functions and a lot of allocation
of short-lived objects so this is
something that a generational collector
collector will do really awesome on but
in JavaScript kors case when the garbage
collector needs to run it actually stops
everything and then it scans the entire
space in parallel I mean you have maybe
eight cores in your system or four cores
and it will use all of them but it does
have to scan the whole space to see
what's live and what's dead and then it
lets a program go on and that leads to
this you know these huge variances here
here here an ongoing I think the outside
color corresponds to ninety percent of
the samples and that red in the middle
is the the middle ten percent you can
think of the the reddest red is a kind
of median line on these so it's just an
indication of this this thing I you know
if you take nothing else from this
presentation is that you know numbers
are really awesome what you're having
you know shootouts and races and
marketing and things like that but if
you actually want to understand you know
anything about your own performance then
you need to treat performance as a
distribution of values and not simply a
number next we've got the regular
expression benchmark and there's not
really anything to say here because the
regular expressions have their own
compiler than in all the engines and
it's not really subject to the
optimizing compiler and so the DFG
doesn't really do anything for us here
and that's that's basically that it it
seems to run but very few times maybe 15
times or so giving us a
I speed up in the loops around which the
regular expressions run but but not on
the regular expressions themselves which
take the bulk of the time finally we're
getting to the end here I think good we
have the splay benchmark which tests
allocations that are very long-lived so
it's terrible for generational
collectors JavaScript court actually
does fairly well in this but what you
can see again is is the huge amount of
variance here we go from know all the
way on the bottom here when we have to
stop the world and you know Mark an
enormous heap to you know something is
quite good up there and and you don't
see the this kind of variance if you
just look at the numbers in the end like
if you just look at the the raw
performance numbers measured over a
second because if you measure a second
you're amortizing all these garbage
collection costs you're not measuring
you know what is your maximum pause time
for example so in this case we're seeing
a pretty poor maximum pause time because
of this stop the world although it's
parallel you know but stop the world
marker and finally we have the newest
addition to the v8 benchmarks I guess if
they're still around and we don't all
move to octane benchmarks or such which
is a navier-stokes benchmark it has a
ray large array of floating-point
numbers but not using the type to raise
so what this really measures is okay
first of all are you doing good floating
point wise does your optimizing compiler
deal with floating point well and can
you automatically turn arrays of
floating point values into a raised of
unbox floats you know and in the case of
v8 they can do this and the case of
javascriptcore you know we can so for
example this get byval fetches a value
at the index with the same range check
and is it a hole and we get we get some
local value I think and then we turned
this value we got into a double which
actually doesn't take very much code but
it's more than if it was an unboxed
array and we knew it was a double
already so yeah no no automatic turning
of arrays into double erase
finally before I close I'd like to
mention how I got this data if you want
JSC and I think there's so many apple
laptops right here you probably have
JavaScript core installed if you can
locate the JSC program if you run it
with dash dash options it gives you a
spit out of knobs you can turn the dash
D will dump bike code which is useful in
together with the app together with a
disassembly if you say show DFG
disassembly but in order to get the time
stamps the information that I showed you
you have to enable some verbose logging
and the the graphs that I showed you I
measured them without the verbose
logging and then I superimposed the DFG
vertical bars after enabling verbose
logging so they were from separate runs
and not entirely identical so you know
don't try to correlate those two
precisely right so back to the hubris I
guess you know javascriptcore is fast as
v8 on its own benchmark and stuff and
and yeah it is and it's faster and it's
slower also because you know we got a
bunch of different tests like we're
doing real great on Richards I say you
know we is a JavaScript core hacker I
don't actually have a dog in this race
but you know do great on Richards not so
great on Delta blue the same on Krypto
really eating it on early boyer but
we're you know picking up on splay yeah
and it is you know a classic example of
you know boy javascriptcore is you know
really killing it on display right but
the pause time it's not on this graph
right you can't see it because those
costs are more dives over the entire
second of collection so yeah that's
that's javascriptcore is optimizing
compiler I'll take some questions now
sure first of all awesome talk love the
tub thank you for being you know BM geek
obvious they do the question I have is
for the butterfly um forgot what that
was not view but something else or is
that intended to be for arrays only is
there a plan for making unboxed values
for objects as well for property on I
think it's for both I haven't talked
with the fellow that it meant but as far
as I understand it's for both sounds
very cool hi hi are there plans to
expose this information for developers
like when are you know certain parts of
the code hot when is your program
actually doing something bad that's
throwing off the digit and whatever
because it does that's actually
something that that we're missing right
now that that kind of information that's
a good question i think the general
answer that is the profiler and the
profiler i believe is hooked up to the
inspector and if it's not that that's a
problem I mean that doesn't really tell
you that it's actually throwing it off I
mean it just you see a decrease in
performance but it doesn't really tell
you you know which part of the code is
it's causing it or you know why your
your your kid is failing basically so is
there I don't know like maybe like a
heat map that would be awesome it's not
even that yet okay so JavaScript co has
three different compilers that seems
like a fairly high number do they really
need that many I don't think so uh I
believe the plan is well the plan is
driven by results right so does the
slowdown something or not and i think
the low-level interpreter has seemed to
work for just munching a lot of code
that doesn't run very often and the DFG
works for hot code and i think the
question is is this baseline JIT
necessary
and it seems it right now to remove it
is not worth it's still in a performance
improvement but I think that's probably
due to inefficiencies or things that
aren't complete in the me optimizing
compiler more than any fundamental
architectural advantage so I'm kind of
talking about so
just to double check as I understand the
the JIT compiler runs in thread so you
have to stop the world in order to
compile so like the bunching of
compilation could cause pauses in and of
itself as well yeah okay I guess that's
it um thank you very much Andy thank you